According
to literature, landfill gas that is
comprised of about 50% methane as CH4
and 50% carbon dioxide CO2 has a heating
value of 500 BTUs per SCF.
Some of this gas is used in a commercial
pipeline which has a required heating
value of 1,000 BTUs per SCF.
If 9% of the gas in the pipeline is
propane with a heating value of 2500 BTU
per SCF, what is the actual percentage
of methane in the landfill gas being
used?
So, this is a problem that we might see
on the environmental exam.
I'm not sure if there is anything in the
reference manual that will be helpful
here, but if you read the problem once
or twice, you may realize that this is
just a simple mass balance problem.
Let's set up the mass balance by taking
some key information from the problem
statement.
We can see that the total heating value
in the pipeline needs to reach 1,000
BTUs per SCF.
We are told that 9% of the gas in the
pipeline is propane
with a heating value of 2500 BTU per
SCF.
This means that we can figure out how
much of the gas is also methane and from
there determine its heating value.
After we find its actual heating value,
we can figure out what the actual
percent of landfill gas is methane by
comparing to the literature values
provided.
So 100% of the gas is in the pipeline
minus the 9% propane means that 91%
remains as methane.
This will be our mass balance statement.
So we can write 91%
methane
plus 9% propane*
[Music]
2500 BTUs over SCF.
Also note that SCF means standard cubic
feet
equals 100%
of the 1,00 BTUs per. So solving for
methane here we can see that the heating
value of the methane in the pipe is
about 851 BTUs per SCF.
[Music]
Next, given that we know the heating
value in the pipe and the heating value
of 50% methane gas, we can determine the
actual percent of methane in this
specific landfills gas.
[Music]
So setting up the ratio we can say that
50% overx
is the same as
500 BTUs per SCF
over 851 BTUs per SCF.
[Music]
Writing this out a little bit more
linearly, we can more easily solve for
X,
which we can see
is going to come out to about 85%.
[Music]
So this problem is very easy to solve as
long as you understand the problem
statement.
Once you figure out the heating value of
the methane mixed with propane in the
pipeline, you can figure out the
percentage of methane that the landfill
gas is comprised of. And that's it.